the ternary operator the ternary or
conditional operator is the only
JavaScript operator that takes three
operands this operator is basically a
shortcut for the if statement it tests
the condition and returns one value or
expression if it is true and another if
it is false so this is the the example
so first it there's a condition here and
then you put a question mark and then
you put if this condition is true it's
going to return this first expression if
it's a false after the colon here you're
going to return the second thing let me
just give you an example first I'll show
you what would look like with an if
statement so we have VAR h equals 19 if
the age is more than or equal to 18
console.log you are an adult else
console that log you are a kid so let's
run that and we'll see in the console
it's saying you're an adult but if we
change that to 15 we run that it's going
to say you are a kid but there is a
different way to do this with a
terminating operator so this whole thing
right here is the ternary operator first
up here you can see the condition this
part is the condition if age is more
than equal to 18 then you always put the
question mark if this is true it's going
to print this you're an adult if it's
false it's going to print you are a kid
so I'm going to clear the console and
then run that again and you were a kid
you were a kid so it prints the U or the
kid from up here and then down here it
prints that you are a kid so this is
just a more succinct way of doing
something if you just have a simple
if-else statement but you can also do
more than one single operation per case
separating them with a comma let me show
you an example okay I just pasted this
in here if we put another variable stop
if the age is more than 18 here's the
question mark so this part right here is
the condition we have the question mark
now this is this whole thing is the
first expression after the question mark
and you can see we have two statements
we have console that law
okay you can go and then there's the
comma and then we assign stop stop
equals false then you have the colon
then you have the whole second
expression here so before is just one
line but now it takes multiple lines and
you can put the comma here that run two
commands in there and the last thing I
want to show you was that a ternary
operation can be inside another ternary
operation so let's scroll up here okay
I'm just going to paste this right in
there
let me just this really quick so you can
see the salm let's so let's look through
this we have a variable of our of our
first check equals false and then this
is the second of our second check equals
false and then there's a VAR access now
let's look through that we use a ternary
operator to to show accesses so this is
the condition first check so we're going
to try to figure out what this access is
going to equal so at first is going to
check this first check UCLES false
remember if it's true it goes to the
first thing before the colon which is
access denied if it's false it goes
right after the colon which is this
whole statement see after the colon
there's a whole nother ternary operator
because you can have more than one
ternary operator together so now it's
going to do this ternary operator it's
going to do the second check well we can
see that second check is false so if it
was if this second check was true it
would say access denied because but
since it's false when we go after the
colon again and it's going to be access
granted now let's just check that by
doing a console that log
and you can see right the bond the
console we have access granted
also from our previous thing we have
sorry you are much too young with the
much kind of cutoff well thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for a link to the code
from this video and remember use your
code for good